good morning believe nation I want you
to know today that anything is possible
and I'm going to share this clip from
rob dyrdek that I think well anything's
possible there you know really that
anything really is possible people
always say like nine you can do anything
you want but like this is a this world
I've done some things in this place and
through this show that like you can't
even dream you know so I think a lot of
entrepreneurs go through these phases
where one day we're up when we feel like
anything is possible we could change the
world that our company is going to work
that we're going to get great results
and then we have other days where we
feel like nothing's possible that is
never going to work that you're never
going to hit the goal that you have in
your head and a lot of times it's
because you don't surround yourself with
people resources and ideas that make you
think bigger and help make you think
that yeah anything is possible when was
the last time any of your friends stood
up and said I believe in you I think
you're going to change the world when
was the last time anybody in your circle
told you that and so the problem becomes
if you're the only person who believes
in yourself there's nobody around you
and worse the people around you are
telling you that it's not possible
telling you that you can't change the
world that you can't accomplish your big
dream then at some point that takes its
toll right that that bruises your
confidence that shatters your ego that
makes you feel like maybe that was just
a crazy dream I'm here to tell you that
it is possible and one of the things
that helps me is looking at families
entrepreneur success stories and looking
at how they started with nothing and
everybody was against them and they had
that little man in their life who is
pounding out on them and they still
manage the bus through and create
something amazing and eventually change
the world I surround myself with their
stories and that's why i also created
this end special series as a selfish way
for me to continually remind myself and
surround myself by greatness the other
thing i find helps us look at the things
in your life that you bought look at
your car look at your laptop look at
your cell phone these were all
inventions all things created by people
who were told that it was not possible
that their idea was not possible and
they didn't listen to those people they
didn't listen to the naysayers and they
created something amazing that is now
standard normal something everybody uses
so you either believe that it is
possible that you can change the world
or you listen to the average people
around you you listen to the naysayers
and let them impose their limiting self
beliefs on you I hope you'll choose the
former and continue to believe thank you
guys so much for watching my question of
the day today is do you think that
anything is possible and if not why not
let me know leave it in the comments
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events press 0